20 años después del 11 de septiembre de
2001 los talibanes usan su bandera sobre
el palacio presidencial en kabul en las
calles sus combatientes patrullan en
vehículos estadounidenses fusil m-16 en
mano la ciudad está tranquila y cada uno
se dedica a sus asuntos la única noticia
oficial del día viene del valle de
panchir una vez más los talibanes
afirman tener en su poder el último
bastión de resistencia a su movimiento
en el país
gracias a dios ya no hay ningún lugar
del país que no esté bajo nuestro
control algunos rebeldes que estaban en
panshir han huido hay paz en todos los
rincones del país el sábado es el primer
día de la semana en afganistán y este
sábado no parece diferente a ningún otro
en apariencia porque cuando la gente de
kabul habla de esta fecha es la amargura
la que domina obvios de excepto ámbar
después del atentado del 11 de
septiembre los estadounidenses
estuvieron en el país durante 20 años
sólo por sus intereses
los problemas que tenemos hoy se deben a
eeuu y como los eeuu otros países nos
han traicionado y pueden ver el
resultado
mientras varios afganos se sienten
traicionados por eeuu
otros como este hombre agradecen a los
talibanes por traer la paz al país